and when I see Kanye that's what I see
in him is I see like this guy that was
so consumed by the world and he grew up
like he grew up in the problem in
society right he was in a single parent
home a single mother home and his mother
kept him from his father so he grew up
like many people grow up Across the
Nation right and like what did that lead
him to he didn't pick a good way you
know let's just call spade a spade here
right he he lived a really immoral life
and it didn't seem to lead him to
happiness right and he he had these
sporadic outbursts and like this crazy
stuff and like he was taking the awards
from Taylor Swift you know and it's like
God's up there looking at him like
you're ruining the gift that I gave you
I think sometimes that's what what
happens right God gives us these gifts
and we use it for evil